what are the different types of
sprinklers well there's a few of them
out there let's talk about the most
common ones i'm dwane smith your
sprinkler warehouse product specialist
let's get started
let's start off with rotors sprays and
rotary nozzles since those three are the
most frequently used in residential
landscapes these three come in pop-ups
and shrub versions so a pop-up is a
sprinkler head that hides below the
surface of the soil and pops up when
it's time to water whether it's a rotor
or spray body they both have a spring
which keeps the sprinkler collapsed
until the valve in the zone opens and
the water pressure pushes up the riser
shrub versions don't pop up and are
installed on shrub sticks rotors have
gears inside the body that rotate this
turret on top
it sprays out a stream of water that
rotates there are partial circle rotors
that rotate from something like 45
degrees to 360 depending on the brand
and model and there are 360 degree only
rotors that just go round and round in a
circle
pop-up heights for rotors are most
frequently four inch
six and 12 inch also with four inch by
being by far the most common and there
are also the shrub models rotors are
usually used to water lawns four inches
great for most grass lawns six and 12
inch varieties are often used for other
types of ground cover
and as i mentioned before there are
shrub style rotors they're put on shrub
sticks and they should only be located
where no one will trip on them they're
primarily placed in flower beds behind
larger plants and shrubs so this is a
spray body
and this
is a spray head
although they're used fairly
interchangeably it's both the body and a
head
i don't know why that is
sprays emit water in kind of a fan shape
spray heads come in a variety of pop-up
heights the most common being two four
six and twelve inch pop-ups and also
shrub models while rotors are usually
used for lawns sprays are more commonly
used for flower beds spray bodies often
are purchased separately from the
nozzles although you can buy some
already put together there are a large
variety of nozzles to meet your ever
need nozzles come in various spray
patterns anywhere from a 45 degree arc
to a full 360 degrees there's some that
have adjustable arcs and there's some
strip patterns that are meant for little
slivers of grass or plant beds
spray nozzles come in various spray
distances that's called the radius by
the way the distance a sprayer rotor
throws water
a shrub style spray body is basically
just an adapter that attaches a nozzle
to a shrub stick
rotary nozzles use moving fingers of
water to irrigate your landscape they
are very water efficient rotary nozzles
fit the very same pop-up bodies as spray
nozzles you can buy them separately from
the bodies or already installed on the
pop-up body for you
like sprays they come in a large variety
of distances and shapes including some
strip patterns as well both sprays and
rotary nozzles tend to use less water
than rotors rotors are more of a
powerhouse covering large distances and
areas they have a larger radius than
most sprays usually 17 feet or more they
need more water pressure ideally around
45 psi sprays need less water pressure
30 psi is optimal in fact too much water
pressure will cause them to mist so if
water pressure is too high you can buy
spray bodies that have pressure
regulating stem and in some states
you're required to by law by sprays with
pressure regulating stems rotary nozzles
operate optimally
around 40 to 45 psi and they have throw
distances anywhere from 8 to 24 feet
next up impacts these are kind of
old-fashioned sprinklers they were
invented in 1933 so they've been around
a while
they are a type of rotor they turn as
they spray impacts are noisier than the
gear driven rotors that i showed you
before
they throw water farther and they tend
to use a lot of water the inside of an
impact is just a tube which means that
there are no gears to clog up so impacts
are better for you when the water source
is something like a pond or a well
they're used a lot in agriculture
because you can get the brass ones like
this which tend to be really sturdy i've
seen them used in nurseries and they're
used in some places to keep dust down
like horse arenas and there are pop-up
versions like this
flood bubblers pour water out under the
ground in a pretty tight radius 18
inches or less
in fact some just kind of drool down
whatever they're attached to they put
water in a confined space really quickly
creating a puddle one of their uses is
inside of a watering basin to saturate
the soil for newly planted trees they
can be used for shrubs or ground covers
in the right situations and they're used
in locations where you really want to
avoid overspray like next to floor to
ceiling windows
hose and sprinklers are a possible
solution if you just need some spot
watering in certain areas and don't want
to install a sprinkler system if you do
use hose end sprinklers a hose in timer
can help you water consistently by
turning on and off the water on a
schedule or you can just set the timer
to run a specified amount of time so you
don't have to worry about forgetting
that you left the water running
in the not quite sprinkler category
there are a variety of sprays jets and
emitters that work with a drip system
drip systems use a lot less water and
lower water pressure to deliver water
more directly to plants to avoid
watering areas that you don't need they
use different tubing and connectors than
a typical sprinkler system although they
can be tied into a regular sprinkler
system on a separate zone
so there's spike bubblers drip emitters
jets sprays and all kinds of interesting
solutions there's also misters and
foggers and there's sprinklers that hang
upside down which have applications in
greenhouses and that's not all
but that's all i'm going to cover today
there are other specialty items that we
don't need to get into for this video
well we covered the basics there are a
variety of other videos we have on
sprinklers that are more in depth and
can help you make a decision on what you
need for your landscape project so go
check those out
questions chat with one of our
incredible customer service agents on
sprinklerwarehouse.com
they really do know their stuff and
they'll get you squared away get
everything you need for that next
landscape project from sprinkler
warehouse a proud member of the heritage
landscape supply group your success is
our heritage sprinkler warehouse
america's most shop sprinkler store
subscribe to our youtube channel for
helpful tips tutorials and general
sprinkler instructions
you